hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational we are already
continuing with Game two of the match
England vs Magnus cross and Magnus lost
in round one he tried that nimzowitsch /
Scandinavian defense but being really
just the he tore it apart and now it's a
call since turn with the white pieces so
here Magnus decides to take things
seriously or or does he well let's see
what happens
so Magnus opens it with E 4 and ding
replies with C 5 he goes for the
Sicilian defense and Magnus goes for f4
sorry about that
4f for the grand prix attack against the
the Sicilian okay we have g6 and now 92
f3 I will Bishop to g7 biding and c3 now
preparing to strike in the center with
d4 we have Knight to f6 now making it a
bit difficult for whites to play d4
since the e4 is under attack so you
either advance it and then we go in some
Knight d5 stuff or you play D 3 which is
what Magnus did we have Knight to c6 and
now Bishop to e2 we have castles by dink
and Magnus also casts castles and now b5
as a Magnus allowed is grabbing some
space on the Queen side preparing bishop
to be 7 and so on and here there is one
game in the database where Queen 31 was
played but here Magnus goes for a3 and
it is a new move so already has a move 8
we have a completely new game
ding continues developing with b6
prepares to develop the the light square
bishop with King to h1 and now a 5
grabbing even more space on the Queen
side preparing b4 with Bishop to e3
continuing development and Bishop to b7
and Knight B to d2 by Magnus we have
before by dink and Magnus ignores it for
the moment with Queen to c2 he wants to
connect rooks so once these trades
happen you can capture and bring the
other blue covert overt a1 if needed so
e 6 and only now capture son before we
have captures captures and rook captures
an a8 here adding recaptures with the
Queen and now keeping an eye on the and
the a1 square and now Knight to c4 and
now with both nice here on c4 and f3
guarding a v e5 is what Carson is
planning here
we have Queen to c2 sorry Queen to b8
guarding the d6 pawn as the knight from
c4 also attacks d6 and now II five by
Magnus attacking the knight and upon so
first the dingos for the bishop on e3
Knight to d5 attacks the bishop and the
Magnus brings it back Bishop to g1 and
only now D characters on e5 so this
leaves the c5 one undefended so Magnus
goes for it Bishop captures on c5
attacks the rook and it's it's always
very unusual to see ding actually move
the rook when it's under attack so ding
here stays true to himself he goes for
Knight captures on f4 and he wants to
start an attack against cross and
skincare so having having such a strong
Bishop and well search for such a strong
night on f4 he doesn't mind giving up
the exchange so Bishop captures any
faith Magnus of course captures it in
the Bishop characters preparing to bring
the other bishop over here to slice over
to the attacking side we have looked at
a 1 now adding another defender to the
bishop and g5 now adding another
defender to the night here but also
preparing g4 with Bishop to f1 adding
another defender to the g2 opponent
which is very important as both of the
knight and the bishop are kind of
attacking it and f6 now strengthening
the pawn structure here we have king
queen to f2 by Magnus as he is under
attack he would very much enjoy trading
queen so he is planning some Queen to b6
ideas and and hoping for a queen trade
somewhere along those lines we have
Knights the e7 biding now and now comes
Knight f2 d2 so bringing the night over
to e4 with Knight the f5 biding and now
Knight to e4 by Magnus putting pressure
on the f6 pawn so Queen to d8 defending
it
but now Magnus immediately goes for
Queen to b6 with an attack and the e6
point okay for the moment is defended by
the knight but basically forcing forcing
the Queen traders also the bishop here
is under attack
so the captures it magnus recaptures in
the now comes King to g7 defending that
ff6 pawn and Knight back to c4 by Magnus
so here we have Knight to h4 going after
that G to pawn
but here Magnus finds a very interesting
idea rook to a-1 here if you go g3 right
away it seems like you're winning
material but then f5 f5 is actually
playable now by black and then you go
into some some real complications now
that this diagonal opens up so first
Magnus played rook to a one he wants to
harass the light square bishop would
rook to e7 and he can always play g3
when it's not so dangerous so here came
to g6 by ding getting his king are out
of rooks way but still rook to e7
attacking the bishop and only now Bishop
to d5 biding but now now Magnus plays g3
and now it's a bit different
ding still goes for f5 and now attacks
this Knight but here you can well feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the the absolute best move while I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations unsporting this tricky
move that basically traps traps White's
Bishop and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show
it's Knight captures on e5 with check
now with the rook controlling the entire
7th rank you can either go at the h6 or
h5 if you go to h5 then just the rook
captures and h7 will be deadly so being
played the King to h6 but now c4 and the
bishop is trapped so here three of these
pieces are under attack and there is
nothing there is nothing you can do here
so whatever you do let's say F captures
on e4 you're just gonna go C CAP force
on d5 and again two pieces are under
attack and it's very interesting you
don't actually lose a piece here well
you do but the thing is that after
Knight captures on d3 you capture with
the bishop on d3 and then after he
captures and III creating a passed pawn
you first capture d captures on e6 as
you need to stop established pawn and
you don't really care about about this
Knight so after D - you're just gonna
stop at the width the rook rook d7 and
after Knight to a5 saving denied getting
it into the game is just gonna capture
on d2 and enjoy this endgame rook and
Knight against the bishop at night which
is of course completely winning and also
Magnus's up upon so after this I see 4
move adding resign the game and
Magnus equalizes the match so already
two games very interesting and still
anything can happen so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it
we're gonna see if this craziness
continues - what will Magnus surprise us
with in the next game and maybe some
maybe some a5 or h5 on the first move
well you never know I would like to
think on Momo hunting I met her solemn
tone of curve it's a Colin Packard and
Thomas Valeri for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Magnus
Invitational until it finishes of course
thank you all I will see soon and have
an excellent rest of your day